each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
I think we'll get started so I'd like to
welcome Irie lampinen hope I'm
pronouncing that properly and ari is a
researcher at the Helsinki institute for
information technology but she's a
visiting scholar at the moment at
Berkeley and her background is social
psychology at the sociology and is what
you told me and she's going to talk
about her work in privacy and social
network so welcome I me thank you thank
you at before that's kind introduction
and thank you for the invitation to give
this talk I'm happy to be here and talk
a lot about the work I've done over the
past several years in the domain of
privacy from a perspective that might be
less less familiar to some of you so
looking at privacy as interpersonal
panda regulation and more specifically
in the context of social network
services but before I get into more
detail about what I mean with all that
let's do a quick tour of campuses to
explain you where I'm coming from so as
trained as a social psychologist at the
University of Helsinki in Finland and
during my studies I did also some some
courses in sociology social policy and
ginger studies so that's kind of
deployed social science background where
I come from and then since 2007 I've
been working at the housing Institute
for information technology and nobody as
I've been affiliated there in three
different research groups so initially I
was working in your business interaction
which is the human-computer interaction
group in the Institute then I for a
while I was affiliated with self-made
media looking into user-generated
content different types of social media
services and then more reason they have
joined the social interaction and
emotion group that was established to
bring together the psychologists and
social psychologists in the Institute so
it's a very interdisciplinary mix of mix
of people bringing together folks from
University of Helsinki and Aldo
university and I've been mainly working
in hei and then csw some internet
studies and on the same come
over in the other side it's also where
I've done my engineering studies so I
double double over in the technological
side I did a bachelor's degree in
information networks which is a program
that combines some computer science with
humanities Business Studies and some
design so this is where I get my
exposure mainly to practitioners and
product design and development cause a
lot of my classmates have gone over to
work in the industry or to set up their
own companies which sometimes led into
interesting collaborations and then
currently as episode and based at UC
Berkeley in California at the School of
Information where I'm working as a
visiting scholar this academic year
doing some new research in the domain of
sharing economy and local online gift
exchange but let's get down to business
so here's a quick roadmap of what to
expect today so I'll first walk you
through some of the key ideas around
what it means to think of privacy is
interpersonal boundary regulation then
I'll get into some detail about
empirical examples of sharing what it
means when we are sharing digital
content or also physical resources via
network technologies and then in the end
i'll come back to implications for
design and policy that this kind of work
may have and during the talk i'd be
happy to take clarifying questions if
you have any but then for the more
substantial discussion i leave time in
the end so let's get back to toast and
after the main talk if that's okay by
you all so when we talk about privacy in
our network H this kinds of photos often
pop up we hear a lot about Big Data
nowadays after the Snowden leaks we are
about a lot about NSA and surveillance
practices and of course what's
underlying a lot of these developments
are the messy ways that people nowadays
can connect online and interact with
each other and all the data that gets
produced in that process and all the
digital traces that we live as we use
network technologies in our everyday
lives so we often think of privacy in
terms of managing data and the kinds of
clean sites that insights that others
might
in from from that data but today I'd
like us to think of it a bit differently
steering away from the data and toward
the people behind the data so thinking
of privacy not just in terms of managing
data but also in terms of managing
interpersonal relations material
resources that we may come to use and
gain access to via network technologies
and overall the somewhat messy whole
that is known as the everyday life so
this picture might seem like a confusing
place to start an inquiry into privacy
but if we think of the chairs and tables
in the big picture as technology then
you might guess that the person hand
standing on top of those is what we
would often think of as the user so
someone who's trying to achieve
something accomplished new things
technology is allowing them to do stuff
that wasn't possible before but it's
also posing new challenges and then what
for me is really interesting in this
picture is not only the efforts that the
user is making but the role of the other
person here so often we think of other
people when we talk of privacy as an
audience for the online sharing but I'm
interested of thinking it also in terms
of what others through in terms of being
collaborators so what we do together so
in brief my work contributes to the
ongoing debate of privacy by making
sense of net network privacy from an
interpersonal perspective and I want to
illustrate some everyday practices young
adults applied to regulate interpersonal
boundaries in the context of network
technology and today I'll focus mostly
on interpersonal boundary regulation
though some of these work derives also
from frameworks of self presentation and
identity work so what is interpersonal
boundary regulation it's a perspective
to privacy that frames privacy as a
process and also one where privacy is
not a feature of data or something that
a person could have but it's something
that we do together and it's not
necessarily only about individuals but
also groups that could have and work on
privacy together
and importantly Irvin Altman who worked
on this framework back in the 70s and
it's a social psychologist was making
the point that it's about achieving the
right amount of interaction with others
so adding both too much and too little
often when we talk about privacy we are
wasting to focus on the part where there
is too much exposure but from this
perspective it can be equally
problematic if we achieve too little so
if you can't connect with others if we
don't get the attention we're looking
for so there's this dialectic interplay
of accessibility and inaccessibility
we're at some moments we want to have a
lot of interaction and at other moments
we want to retreat and so this is not
something that is only relevant in the
domain of online interaction but it's
really called all of social life and the
way I want to define it is that it
constitutes of the effort to achieve
desirable degrees of social interaction
but also about building and sustaining
relations with others and with the self
so this is where self-presentation
identity work come into play and there
are all kinds of different practices and
mechanisms for achieving these goals and
we'll talk some of those later on and as
this framework is now being applied to
network settings there are some key
aspects that are different from what
Eltman was looking at back in the 70s
when he was thinking of physical space
and the kind of things we need to take
into consideration nowadays so with all
of the network technologies we have data
there is persistent it's easy to
replicate its scales it can spread
enormously fast and it's searchable and
all of these things have have
repercussions for the way we can
organize and interact with others and
since the early 2000s there's been
working applying this framework to
network settings often in ways where the
focus has been on online interaction
although essentially when the framework
was set up it was about offline
interaction and what I've been trying to
do in my work is to bring these two
together because in many ways it often
does not make sense to make this
distinction between online and offline
we
well looking at everyday life stores two
are essentially collapse together and to
make sure that we're on the same same
note about what we're talking about when
we discuss social media so here's Alison
and poets definition of social network
sites as communication platforms where
people have uniquely identifiable
profiles where they can articulate their
connections with others and where they
can consume produce and interact with
straighten streams of user-generated
content and I tend to address this
category of services as social network
services instead of sites and I do that
on purpose to highlight how it's not
necessary just a website we're talking
about but these services like Facebook
tend to have a presence across the web
we encountered them in many different
ways not just on the side but also
through apps on our smartphones on other
sites where we may be reading content
and maybe liking that and so on and if
we think of this context then important
aspects of it are that people may be
sharing content with multiple groups at
once they may be sharing content on
behalf of others so it's not just people
working on their own self presentations
but also with others there may be
automated ways to do sharing so we may
not be pressing publish every time we
want to show something online and
finally sharing online and offline are
connected in multiple ways and now
sharing is a notion that gets thrown
allowed a lot when we're talking about
people working online we often talk
about sharing and it doesn't really
necessarily say much to what we're
talking about I use this word as an emic
notion since when I talk with people who
use social network services they don't
think of their actions in terms of
interpersonal boundary regulation that's
a very squirrel scholarly social science
notion but sharing is something that
comes up a lot when people talk about
their activities online and it's also
something that SNS providers are using a
lot in constructing and strength during
this rhetoric around sharing and sharing
gets both celebrated and lamented
we hear about participation in social
network sites being very narcissistic or
leading to lots of privacy and then only
more optimistic end of things people
talk about social capitals or the ways
we can build maintain and benefit from
social relationships and also all the
opportunities that come with what's
termed as big data so are the
possibilities of doing data rich things
once all these interactions have been
tracked and I also want to highlight
that sharing is not a monolith so in my
work I try to draw a distinction between
primarily three types of sharing so
there's the sharing of manually selected
digital content as would often be the
case on Facebook for example then there
are automatically tracked and published
information so that's something where
people are setting up a tracker and then
that just automatically stream state
behavior online to their profiles and
then finally favors and physical objects
so also the kinds of sharing where we
actually take an item and share that
together with others we are sharing then
maybe who use rather than anything else
and with that I want to get over to some
empirical examples so I've done a series
of explorative studies in this domain
with my colleagues over the past years
and today I will be walking you through
with some examples of both sharing
digital content and sharing on physical
resources and what these two lines of
work have together that they're both
mainly based on interviews with people
who are actually engaging in these
practices primarily individual
interviews but also focus group
interviews so I do mainly qualitative
work I talk with people and then try to
clean inside from from what they are
saying about the things they do and how
they think about the things they do so
and and in the second example I'll talk
goes a little bit about a living lab
project in this way that took place the
HIIT over the past several years so
first coming from the manual sharing
backgrounds
people actually making decisions case by
case to share content here's a map we
drew with some colleagues on the
different binary regulation practices
people have when they are interacting
with social network services so those
practices may be collaborative where we
actually actively engage with others or
they may be individuals such as making
some changes to our privacy settings in
a service or or making choices on your
own then there's a distinction between
prevention and correction so do we try
to make sure that everything goes well
or are we actually working with the
plunder and trying to make sure that no
further harm is being done and then as a
final distinction mental all original
practices so what kind of mindsets do we
take to watch sharing and then more the
more behavioral actionable end of things
that we can actually observe people
doing so that's just a map of the kinds
of practices we're talking about when we
think of boundary regulation and first
if we look at the facebook example so we
did a study on sharing on behalf of
others on facebook and we went in with
this notion of all right so people are
socially embedded and when they are
trying to manage the way they come come
to be seen on social network services
it's not just a matter of what they do
themselves but also what other people do
so do your friend share pictures of you
are they how are they commenting the
content you share and so on but we
wanted to understand how people who are
using Facebook think of these distinct
so we conducted series of studies or
interviews with University students in
the Helsinki metropolitan area to see
how they think about it and I did what
we found is that they are very cognizant
of the fact that other people have some
control over their self presentation so
it's not just a matter of their
individual effort but instead of overt
practices of cooperation there was the
strong reliance on trust and mutual
consideration so people essentially
instead of doing something visible they
wanted to just feel that they can trust
other people so their friends would not
be sharing photos say that are
compromising
or so on and and there was a lot of talk
about the shared rules of disclosure in
the interviews but as we then try to
probe probe further what we found is
that these shared rules had rarely been
discussed so people had the sense that
other people know what they want and
what they expected of them but they had
rarely expressed their wishes to others
and this can of course be very
complicated in terms of then how do you
take other people into account if you
don't really know what they would be
expecting especially when we are dealing
with something like Facebook where
people often have different groups who
may be dealing with very different sets
of norms and then over on a study on
last.fm so last film is an internet
radio and music website where people can
find and discover new music and tell
about the musical tastes and we were
specifically interested in its system
for tracking music listening that is
called a scrubber which is a friendly
spyware that records all the music
listening that is happening on the
connected devices and then reports that
in real time to the users last.fm
profile and so here we wanted to
understand how boundaries are regulated
when sharing is automated because if you
are thinking of the men you are sharing
example then there are ways two ways to
think of it where you have a clear point
of control but with less of him you just
enable the system and then sharing goes
on and what we found is that well this
automated sharing in cannabis mechanisms
obviously don't take the need a way to
regulate sharing and regulate boundaries
and people had interesting ways of
trying to work with what was being
shared while they were trying to be
truthful and just share their behaviors
and instead of simply refusing to
publish their information they might
actually instead change the music
listening behavior itself in order to
control what was being published so next
to self presentation we also see here a
case of several reflection where people
would look at their profiles see what
they had been up to and then based on
that tried to think through what they
wanted to say yes
people have really looked at what
happened when sharing was on and what
happened when sharing was often they saw
that they were the shift in listening
behavior so yes yeah that's correct our
work has been self-reported so it's
interviews in in depth where people
explain what they do and where they
would themselves confess that they had
been tampering in some ways with the
sharing that was happening or deciding
to change what they were doing but
definitely would be interesting to in
fact try and see what the data could
reveal in this case and then as a
follow-up to these two studies we looked
reanalyzed tea sets from this interview
material sets from these two studies
together to understand how technological
affordances and social norms were into
playing in the way people were
regulating their boundaries and what we
found is that sharing lie automated and
manual mechanisms at least in two cases
these two cases were sanctioned
differently so on facebook social
acceptance concerned mainly sure sharing
per se so are you sharing too much or
too little do you have too many friends
on your profile is the content that
you're sharing too mundane tones kinds
of considerations came up in the
interviews a lot where's unless the fam
the social acceptance was actually more
focused on the actual behavior
underlying this earring so the musically
stealing so people were more talking
about the kinds of musical tastes that
you are expressing by by what you do but
beneath this winner of difference the
normalizing speech we found in the
interviews in both cases was focused on
this goal of being real and let me
explain a little bit how how that comes
about and what it means so there's all
this work going around presentation of
authenticity so people in their sharing
and in their online profiles are
supposed to be come off as being real
and what that means is that all kinds of
artificiality faking
and excessive enhancing or once image
were condemned and people who were
caught doing something like this so
strategically presenting themselves in a
certain way were frowned upon but
interestingly depending on the sharing
mechanism in question and of course on
both of these cases there are ways to do
automated sharing on Facebook and there
are ways to do man you are sharing on
last.fm but we focused on on the parts
where each of them goes goes one way so
on Facebook the easiest way to make sure
that you would not become then for us to
minimize your sharing that would lead
you to having lesser problems lesser
risk of being caught for doing something
that you were not supposed to be doing
and unless the fam on the contrary it
was best to maximize your sharing so the
more you were streaming the more
reliable you were seeing to be seen and
this is an example chest of how
appearing authentic in ones online
sharing is not really a simple outcome
of being truthful or just being you but
there's all this work happening behind
if you are successful in your profile
work then you come off as being real in
the right way so authenticity in this
case is very complex and then over the
other example so the sharing of physical
resources and this is a line of work
that is quite different from the social
network services and maybe less often
thought of in terms of privacy and an
even a social network services so this
is my way you would hear about the
sharing economy or collaborative
consumption where people are enabled to
engage in different diverse types of
social exchange goods and services often
in their local neighborhoods and i want
to show you quickly two examples so
local online exchange by the system
share tribe and network hospitality why
a couchsurfing so I initially got into
this line of work to a project called
other sizzle where we essentially built
a living lab to the Aldo campus in in
Helsinki and the project was devised to
develop and study social media for
campus life and we did design some
services in the project ourselves and
then we also came up with
platform where students could could
design their own services and the most
important outcome for me from this
project was a service that was initially
called Cassie which was intended for
users to lend rent give away and sell
items given get help or share rides with
people nearby so essentially for people
to work together in their geographically
local contexts connect first online and
then have exchanges that take place
face-to-face and this is how I stumbled
upon the very sharing economy early on
in 2009 I think is when we first
launched the initial version of this
service and over the year the sir yes
the service was launched as a startup
that is nowadays known as share tribe
and we continued to collaborate with the
founders did you stay and so we first
studied users by afterwards we've now
done some work also with single parents
in Oakland California and are looking at
different different kinds of contexts so
going beyond the student use but an
initial study that was still done at
aalto looked at people's experiences of
this kind of local online exchange and
what we found in brief was that people
were very eager to contribute and very
averse to indebtedness and here to again
we are dealing with interviews with
active users so this might not represent
the whole of the community and there's
the issue of self reporting so do people
just want to come off as being very nice
as they are talking talking with their
interviewers but these similar results
have been found in other studies on time
banking and so on so there is reason to
believe that this is actually to some
degree the case that we found and also
what we found that they were interesting
user behaviors to lessen negative
feelings of indebtedness so people might
offer small tokens of appreciation get
around understanding the nature of
indirect generalized exchange so the
idea of paying it forward not needing to
reciprocate directly with the person you
are interacting with also trying to
manage expectations by Framing offers
and requests carefully minimize the
effort
your exchange partner needs to go to and
then partnering and exchanging for a
third person so instead of asking help
for yourself you might instead ask it
for your housemate or for your friend
and in that sense you're not actually
the one who's getting the benefit so it
kind of gets you out of the reciprocity
loop in some ways and then there's
another example of sharing physical
resources via network technologies is
the project I did while I was interning
at MSR New England back in 2012 so I was
looking at network hospitality which
here you can see the definition Jennifer
mods has provided so again here comes
this idea of connecting with other
people buy online tools but then
engaging in relationships and exchanges
offline and face-to-face and I was
focusing on couchsurfing specifically
which is always where people can sign up
to offer and ask for accommodation as
they travel or are visiting places and
this is non-monetary Airbnb would be a
similar example by the case where people
are actually paying for this hospitality
which changes the dynamic somewhat and
so the main portion of this study was
looking at how people host together as
multi person households how they
regulate their collective boundaries so
how they work with who they invited
their shared home and what spaces they
make available and so on but also how do
they add into individuals needs while
doing this and what I found was that
there is a strong striving for consensus
so only hosting when everyone is on
board trying to share and delegate
responsibilities over hosting taking
turns in who's who's managing not so
much the online profile there was often
only one person in charge but as the
visitors were entering the domestic
space who would be entertaining them who
would be taking care of their needs so
that others if they needed to attend to
other business could could do that
leveraging the profile again to indicate
expectations and requirements and then
also working around temporal and spatial
track structures in the home to make
hosting as smooth as possible and
another aspect of
study that came out in cscw this spring
a few weeks back was the way people were
sharing accounts Celeste they were
hosting as a household together they
were actually often only using one
profile to represent multiple people
which is not usual in social network
services as much so there were they were
facing challenges in presenting multiple
people in a single profile in
coordinating negotiations over access to
domestic space so as they were getting
requests from boosters wanting to come
and stay with them how would they keep
everyone aware and make sure that
everyone was consenting and so on and
then finally interesting issues
regarding reputation so if the profile
is under the name of one of the
household members while all are actually
participating in the hosting how do the
ones who another's present or visible in
the online profile get to also benefit
of the reputation that has been a good
accumulated together over time in case
of language life changes and so on so
those are the empirical examples I
wanted to show you NS a recap so
widespread eruption of social network
services is disrupting some of the
central premises of interpersonal
regulation such as the way we've used to
rely on space and time to know who's
hearing our thoughts and the things we
are saying there's enormous diversity in
sharing so it's not just status updates
or not just one single thing but there
are many different types of content and
things that are being shared and the
related practices for panda regulation
may be very diverse as well and finally
I'd like to argue that interpersonal
panda regulation in this context is best
understood as a cooperative process also
when taken to the context of social
network services so Eltman was always
arguing that it is something that people
do together and even if our thoughts and
design around services often considers
only the individual user it seems that
social life is still pushing us toward
this place where what we really do need
to cooperate with others to regulate
and as some implications for design I
tend to be of the mindset where I don't
want to go and tell designers how their
designs should look like I'd rather work
with them and provide some insights that
are coming out of our research so a core
question of course is how to encourage
and sustain participation in whatever
systems we are building and providing
and so some issues to consider in the
case of manual sharing how to better
support the cooperative action aspects
so a lot of the work nowadays is focused
on individuals but actually people try
to work together so how to take that
pillar into account in design then in
automated sharing how to allow for
expressing and explaining the meanings
attached to behavior so if you are only
streaming your behavioral data you might
be doing one behavior for diverse
different reasons and you might want to
explain say you are listening to attract
as you a song that you find to be very
embarrassing but maybe it's funny in a
given context where you are listening to
it with another friend and you might
want to explain that instead of just
having it streamed to your profile where
it just looks curious like why were you
doing that like is that your musical
taste then in local online exchange how
can we redirect the feelings of
indebtedness toward positive outcomes
instead of the frustration hesitation
they may lead to where reciprocity
really is an organizing principle for
communities so how can we leverage that
sense and willingness to reciprocate
instead of leaving people feeling that
they can't take part because they don't
have enough to offer in in return and
then in terms of network hospitality
that I just talked about how do we
consider the collective efforts and the
ways people share accounts so again
looking beyond the individual and then
in terms of policy I think the ways this
kind of work and provide can contribute
to policies by complicating some of the
narratives around technology use by
depicting the lived experience
experiences of people the experiences of
sharing and how that often happens
together also by highlighting issues of
access to power
dissipation so the questions of
reputation and benefiting of a
reputation which presumably is becoming
more and more important as as a lot of
the resources we are using are available
through online systems and the biases
that may inadvertently be introduced or
perpetuated and then also the resources
needed to use free services so this is
something that came up a lot in our work
with the single parents in Oakland where
they had a clear need for a lot of the
things of local online exchange could
provide them but they did not really
have the time to invest in building
their relationships with people around
them that they would have needed to have
to feel safe in engaging with these
exchanges such as organizing right chef
for their children and thus they often
became plugged from actually using those
services and getting the resources they
needed I also think we can provide
granularity and explicate the
differences between those practices of
sharing and make help policymakers
understand how online sharing is not
just one thing and it's not just
Facebook but it's actually varied others
and I think a very prone area for this
work is the sharing economy where there
is currently a lot of debates on going
around how do we organize crowd labor
how do we organize crowdfunding how to
do it x Airbnb exchanges how should ride
sharing be related to the taxi industry
and so on and there is a clear need for
empirical insight to understand what's
going on there and finally to conclude
so privacy if we think of it in terms of
interpersonal under regulation is more
than just an issue of an individual's
control over data and information it's
also about interpersonal relations and
how we relate to others how we think of
ourselves and how others are thinking
about us and so with this work I really
want to call for reconsidering privacy
beyond the individuals beyond the notion
of an individual user and also across
the many online and offline settings in
which people come together so when we
talk of privacy these days we shouldn't
really focus only on the online parts
but really combine it together with the
offline to look at the everyday life
a whole and I want to leave you with two
questions so going forward it will be
really interesting to understand better
how people do and how they good track
manage and share intimately personal
data and also how could they be or how
could we be empowered to leverage the
existing data by ourselves in more
meaningful way so in talks with big data
it is often not the people who who the
data is about that are in charge and
that's something where there could be
interesting possibilities in in looking
at that and I want to acknowledge all
the co-authors that have been working
with me over the years on these projects
and the colleagues at the different
institutes that i've been working at and
with that I'll open to your questions
and comments thank you so thanks for the
talk I'm not from your field and we use
very different methodologies and I'm I
didn't see much evidence presented in
this talk so in in previous talks that
I've attended for from this type of
research people had at least some kind
of word snippets you know when you say
something like there was eager pneus to
contribute or aversion to in-depth
admiss where does that where's the
evidence for that do you have witnesses
for that are there like snippets of text
where people have said I hate being in
depth to people or can you can elaborate
a little bit on this evidence yeah
absolutely clearly and that was the
point where I was leaving a lot of that
out in order to just give you a prod
prod review of the types of teams that
I've been looking at but yes that's
exactly the de mode of presenting that
you would find in the papers we've been
writing and for instance in the study on
reciprocity indeed we did have a lot of
people explaining how either they were
hesitant to participate because they
felt that if they hadn't offered
something to others yet then they
couldn't first accept something for
others or if they were accepting a favor
from someone else then they wanted to
right away launch into into giving
something to others and so for instance
for the five categories here all of them
have been derived from the interviews
from the things that people were saying
how they were describing their exchange
experiences so we interviewed all
together I think 11 people and we had
closer to 50 exchange experiences that
we went through with them each of them
describing the kinds of exchanges they
had engaged in and then telling about
the difficulties they had had in them
and what had been rewarding and so on so
yes that's that's correct so a big issue
that comes that we face generally when
taking these sort of studies is the
biases that are introduced by the
subjects so of course there are framing
biases in the sense that they are
talking to a researcher and they might
not feel comfortable and sort of
revealing everything and there are also
subject biases people say from India or
China might sort of think about sharing
in a much in a very different way than
somebody and say Oxford or Cambridge
right so have you considered the sources
of these biases and sort of when we sort
of think about building systems for
everyone on the planet I mean how what
are the implications how do you actually
even go about reasoning about these
variations great points and a good good
question and I think well one thing to
take into consideration is that there
are definitely biases when we are
working with interviews with people in
terms of what they report and not only
whether they are being honest with us or
not but but the way they would talk
about things when they are asked to talk
about them so some element of reflection
is always introduced in in that process
so there is no way to really get it get
the raw raw experience recorded but that
of course is the case for
all types of empirical material so if we
are looking at the behavioral data then
we would would see what what has
actually happened but we might not have
any insight into why it had happened or
with what kinds of meanings people
attached to them and then in terms of
user groups 1 1 part to think about that
is that a lot of the work I do tries to
come up with different kinds of concepts
and define the behaviors that are out
there due to some degree and kind of
work in a more conceptual level rather
than try to claim that this is how
everyone works but clearly it's not not
how everyone works but going forward I
totally agree with you that this work
has now been done mostly with students
and mostly with people residing in
Finland which is a very narrow pocket of
the humanity as a whole and it is useful
to to think about and consider different
types of user groups and that's one
reason why I have so much enjoyed the
project we've now been working on with
the single parents at Oakland who have
very different perspectives and you are
absolutely correct that if we go to a
culture that is then more further
removed from from the Finnish culture
then then the state's say to a shower or
so what we might find very different
things and people in our field are doing
fantastic work in in that perspective
also in going to look how just how
people are even using the internet to
begin with saying Africa if if phones
are the main touch point to to web and
so and so that's definitely good points
and in designing for everyone it is it
is a challenge but thinking through just
introducing the human elements can
already I believe be helpful though it
only gets us so far so we definitely
need the more data-driven side as well
um I was just thinking about how you
have framed some of the things in terms
of big data and how you set up a
difference between manual and automatic
but I wonder with big date have there's
some other category don't know what it
would be called because it's naughty
there's no sort of necessary intent on
the part of the person in some ways that
and so you get these sort of interesting
ideas of pseudonymous data that you know
appears through use rather than what
you've sort of explicitly rejected so I
just wonder how that might reflect on
these ideas of personal management of
boundaries how do we stop that have a
say on these kinds of data that we have
no real sort of explicit control of in
terms of our presentation yeah great
question thank you Alex so yeah it's
it's right in this this work so far I've
been focusing on the parts where people
are actually deciding to share so even
even in the case of automatic sharing
they still at some point enable a system
and choosing to to have that sharing
happen but then of course a lot of the
actions we take online are being tracked
in different ways and leave traces
behind without us necessarily even
realizing that that's happening or at
least not having access to the records
that are being produced and I think
that's a separate category in some ways
of of this sense but it's also something
that I'm thinking of with these two
questions here we're often the case is
that there might be all these rich
sources of data of us but we don't
necessarily were not the ones who have
access to them and I think that my data
and open data movements are are trying
to make very very interesting work in
that domain in in terms of advocating
for people to have better access to
their own data but then beyond that
often kind of technische I think there
is also a place for thinking through
like how do and that's what i mean by
the empowering here how do we help
people who do not come
from technical backgrounds and are not
necessarily right away as fascinated
with the data they're producing to
understand that the data is out there
and also engage with it in meaningful
ways but that's really something for for
the future to work on that that side of
the project I well I had one so I read I
expected to see in your list of design
implications was something about the
giving users the ability to revoke or
delete data about themselves and you
didn't mention that so I wondered
whether you thought that was too
technically difficult if it wasn't a
significant issue or or or what it is
yeah I was yeah being very brief mainly
for the sake of time it definitely is an
issue that comes comes up and I think
the interesting part from the projects
that we've done is the fact that how
that that often is not really an
effective way for interpersonal boundary
regulations or well first of it's often
technically not really really valid and
valid idea to really get anything
removed from the web but even socially
as soon as something has been out there
the kind of corrective work that would
come from the leading often risk
actually making the problems bigger than
they were to begin with because if we
think of the authenticity requirement i
was talking about then if others noticed
that you are actually trying to hide
something that might just emphasize the
importance of that and then they really
think that that was not an important
important thing but the leading
definitely is something that was coming
up and it's also an issue that
especially comes up in the cases of
people sharing on behalf of others so
then if it's your own sharing you have
some control to make it at least
invisible even if you can't necessary
permanently erase the record but if it's
someone else who's been sharing
information about you you may not have
the tools available to to do so and it's
also debatable to what degree you should
have it so technically undesigned and
and even ethically a very complicated
question of how it should work yeah i
agree i think it is a technically
complex issue but also socially complex
as you point out but i guess the point I
was making is that we don't really have
very many options available to us to be
able to manage that process yeah it
doesn't seem to be kind of a feature
that designers of these services take
into account ya know and I guess that
often goes against the interest of of
the service providers and then I think
what's really interesting from the user
side of these things is how how strong
people have been interviewing have been
kinda adapting to that idea where they
really place the emphasis on prevention
and try to just make sure that there
would never be the need to to delete
because they know that that's not really
an option that is perfectly available
for them Thanks hi um so I just had a
question because you were talking a
little bit about people who are sharing
on in the context of couchsurfing for
example so you have entire household and
you might have five people who are all
sort of represented digitally by a
single profile yeah so what kinds of I
guess other things should be thinking
about in terms of this sharing of
profiles or the creation of profiles
that aren't necessarily this sort of
individual one-to-one mapping where it's
sort of one too many or many to one so
there I think in terms of if we think of
the accounts now and of the profile
Scouts roofing is an interesting example
in that they actually allow people to
indicate that the profile is about
several people but then the profile
fields still look very much alike to the
case where it's just an individual who's
who's building it so that's one one
issue where then it might be difficult
to explain that well you can describe
that this is a household of these five
people but it might be difficult to
explain like well this is this person
and that person and that person and how
they are different and how they may have
different expectations so you would be
pushed toward this uniform uniform
presentation and then also
what I found in the study was they was
often just one person in the household
who was really in charge of the online
profile and the others wouldn't
necessarily even know much about the
reputation they were gaining or the
reviews they were writing or understand
how how the profile was was working so
there's the issues of representation
that come into play and then also
coordination so if if the profile is
then directing requests as emailed just
the one person that also pushes the word
a single person being in charge of the
whole whole instead of others and in
terms of them design alternatives to
this one option would be to try and
think of it in terms of a puzzle where
its individual could have their own
little bill piece that then can be
combined together to make for a
situation where say if the household
disintegrates so a child is moving out
or housemates are changing cities or
whatever the case for the life change
maybe they could in some ways take their
self presentation and their reputation
with them without needing to start from
scratch but of course that also risks
introducing all kinds of complexities
that may be undesirable so there are
definitely tricky trade-offs to to work
around in designing for 4shared use in
in this sense
so I'm I didn't see anything you talk
about kind of multiple online so as a
person going online to these groups you
might feel secure and kind of yeah you
have different social groups and you
might share different ideas I'm thinking
or social and work in the professional
world there's more and more online
presence how were your thoughts about
keeping those separate you see news
lines all the time where they collide
and professional people their reputation
is damaged because of things they may
have said in it what they thought was a
socially safe yeah yeah no yeah that's
absolutely an important part of this
this part something that I wasn't
focusing on today so this would be the
case of sharing with multiple groups at
once and indeed one of the ways that has
been coming up in our interviews and
also in other people's work is Easter
segregations of profiles two different
services and one of the main
distinctions that came up in to facebook
study was that people were using
facebook for more of the personal life
and then trying to push all all
professional things over to LinkedIn to
to help strike that balance but then of
course often the boundaries end up
leaking anyways and then there are ways
to try and work with those division
lines also within an individual service
Facebook wouldn't be encouraging people
to have over there actually betting
people from having multiple profiles but
then say on twitter that would be a more
common case we're even on twitter itself
people would have multiple profiles for
different uses sending was my things
yeah happening which you have no control
over and suddenly someone doesn't do
guys are buying and suddenly got a match
between spread on this one yeah yeah no
unless yeah that's absolutely a risk and
i think that's a risk that often people
do not take into account so and of
course here I've been focusing on the
interpersonal side so how do we try to
make things work among individuals and
then in that sense people don't often
think of the more big data aspects of it
but it's
absolutely correct that the risk is out
there that even if socially for now it
would be viable to just separate then if
someone starts data mining and really
wants to combine combine things they
might get to a much more complete
picture of you than you were intending
to ever have integrated but that is
largely concerned that at least at the
time of these interviews people who are
not talking about though they may be
should be